this statement is on behalf of the
government and the foreign secretary who
is attending the funeral of a close
family member
ten days ago Fierce fighting broke out
in Khartoum it has since spread to
omdurman Darfur and other Sudanese
cities
as members of this house will know a
violent past struggle is ongoing between
the Sudanese Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces
Madam Deputy speaker the situation in
Sudan is extremely grave more than 427
people have been killed including five
Aid workers over 3 700 people have been
injured
before this violence began the
humanitarian situation in Sudan was
already deteriorating we now estimate
that approximately 16 million people a
third of the Sudanese population are in
need of humanitarian assistance
these numbers I regret to inform the
house are likely to rise significantly
while the paramilitary rapid support
forces announced a 72 hours ceasefire
from 0-500 hours London time on the 21st
of April to Mark the holy Festival of
Eid it did not hold
given the rapidly deteriorating security
situation the government took the
difficult decision to evacuate all
British Embassy staff and their
dependents to fulfill our duty to
protect our staff as their employer
this highly complex operation was
completed yesterday
the operation involved more than 1200
Personnel from 16-air assault Brigade
The Royal Marines and the Royal Air
Force
I know the house will join me in
commending the brilliant work of our
colleagues in the ministry of Defense as
well as The Bravery of our service men
and women for completing this operation
successfully amidst extremely dangerous
circumstances
I also want to pay tribute to our
International partners for their ongoing
cooperation in aligning our rescue
responses and I want to express my
admiration for the work of the crisis
center in the foreign office where over
200 officials are working 24 7 and
seamlessly across government to
coordinate the UK response
Madam Deputy speaker the Safety and
Security of British Nationals continues
to be our utmost priority our ability to
support British Nationals has not been
impacted by the relocation of British
Embassy staff the evacuation team will
continue to operate from a neighboring
country alongside the foreign office in
London which is working throughout the
day and night to support British
Nationals and push for a ceasefire in
Sudan
we are asking all British Nationals in
Sudan to register their presence with us
the roughly 2 000 British Nationals
registered with us already are being
sent sometimes with great difficulty at
least daily updates by text and email
this step helps enable us to remain in
contact with them whilst we find a safe
passage from Sudan
movement around the capital remains
extremely dangerous and no evacuation
option comes without grave risk to life
Khartoum airport is out of action energy
supplies are disrupted food and water
are becoming increasingly scarce
internet and telephone networks are
becoming difficult to access
we continue to advise all British
Nationals in Sudan to stay indoors
wherever possible we recognize
circumstances will vary in different
locations across Sudan so we are now
asking British Nationals to exercise
their own judgment about their
circumstances including whether to
relocate but they do so at their own
risk
ending the violence Madame Deputy
speaker is the single most important
action we can take to guarantee the
safety of British Nationals and everyone
in Sudan the Prime Minister the foreign
secretary the Secretary of State for
defense and I have been in continuous
contact with allies and with key
Regional Partners since the outbreak of
violence to agree a joint approach to
both evacuation and de-escalation of
vows
over the weekend the Prime Minister
spoke to his counterparts including
Egyptian president sisi and the
president of Djibouti
the foreign secretary was in contact
with the Kenyan president the U.S
Secretary of State and foreign Ministers
of France Germany the UAE Saudi Arabia
Djibouti Sweden turkey Cyprus and the EU
High representative for foreign and
security policy the defense secretary
engaged with counterparts in Djibouti
the U.S France and Egypt I have spoken
to the African Union and the prime
minister in Exile of Sudan upon whom so
many hopes rested further escalation of
this conflict particularly if it spills
over into neighboring countries would be
disastrous as we continue to make clear
there must be a genuine and Lasting
ceasefire
Madam Deputy speaker we undertake to
keep the house informed as the situation
develops today all MPS will receive a
second dear colleague letter from the
foreign secretary and myself this will
hopefully help to answer a number of
frequently asked questions to assist
honorable and right honorable members in
supporting their constituents Madam
Deputy speaker I will continue to be in
close contact with the house and provide
updates wherever possible in the coming
days I commend this statement to the
house
I'm very grateful Madam Deputy speaker
and I'd like to thank the minister for
advanced sight of his statement and for
keeping me informed over this weekend my
right honorable friend the shadow
foreign secretary is returning from
Kenya this evening and he continues to
discuss developments with African
leaders there
so first can I join the minister in
paying tribute to the bravery and
professionalism of our Armed Forces
involved in the operation to evacuate
British diplomats and their families
from Sudan on behalf of Labor I'd like
to thank the 1 200 UK Personnel involved
in this very difficult Mission including
those from 16 assault Brigade The Royal
Marines and the RAF
yet our relief at the success of this
Mission doesn't alleviate Our concern
for the several thousand British
Nationals still trapped in Sudan and big
growing violence and many will be
frightened and desperate to leave but
uncertain of their next move or how that
is how all the assistance that this
government will be able to offer them
what they need to hear is a clear plan
on how the government will support those
still in danger how they will
communicate with them and when and while
we maintain the unified International
pressure for a permanent ceasefire we
are clear the government should be
evacuating as many British Nationals as
possible as quickly as possible
none of us are in any doubt as to the
complexity of the task or the difficulty
of the situation on the ground yet we
know a partner countries have evacuated
significant numbers of their Nationals
already 700 by France in Germany 500 by
Indonesia 350 by Jordan 150 each by
Italy and Saudi Arabia a hundred by
Spain African Partners including Nigeria
Ghana and Kenya are planning action too
and France included UK Nationals in its
airlift we thank them but it raises some
really serious questions
can the minister address why partner
countries have been able to evacuate
sizable numbers of their Nationals so
far as well as diplomats and dependents
but the UK is not can he confirm if the
government has evacuated any UK
Nationals who were not employees of the
embassy or their dependents can he
confirm how many UK Nationals have been
evacuated by our International partners
where the embassy staff able to complete
a full and proper shutdown including
dealing with any sensitive material
and given the communications
difficulties how can we effectively
coordinate a second phase of the
evacuation
naturally questions will be asked about
whether the government has learned the
lessons of the chaotic Afghanistan
withdrawal
we need to understand why the
International Community and the UK
government as Security Council pen
holder was seemingly flat-footed by a
conflict that as we know was a clear and
recognized risk
can the government give us a current
assessment of Wagner's role in
supporting the rsf
but the immediate priority must be to
make our Nationals away
to escape violence that is not their
making and we should remember also that
this conflict is not the making of the
Sudanese people either
responsibility for that squarely lies
with a few generals putting personal
interests and ambition above the lives
of fellow citizens the resistance
committees are organizing Mutual Aid
despite terrible risks people fleeing
cartoon by Road are being sheltered and
supported in The Villages they pass
people who only want peace Justice and
democracy are showing again their
solidarity and their extraordinary
resilience so can I ask the minister to
detail the steps that the UK will be
taking with Partners to address the
looming Humanity Christ humanitarian
crisis this conflict is driving
the International Community including
all of our partner all of our partners
need to send a clear and United message
the generals cannot secure any future
that they would want through violence
the fighting needs to stop and it needs
to stop now
minister
well Madam Deputy speaker I Thank The
Honorable lady very much for her
comments and in particular what she said
about the work of the Armed Forces she's
entirely right about the both the
bravery and uh the incredible difficulty
with which they executed this operation
uh so uh well she asked me about the
British Nationals who are trapped in
cartoon and were widely in uh Sudan and
I can tell her that we are looking at
every single possible option for
extracting them and she acknowledged
that this was a very complex area I can
only say to her that it certainly was
she referred to our partner countries
and as we know when the French were
seeking to evacuate their diplomats and
some people from The Wider French
government platform which is what she
referred to they were shot at as they
came out through the embassy Gateway and
I understand that one of the Special
Forces is Gravely ill
um she asked uh also about uh the why it
was that the UK diplomats were evacuated
that was because we believed they were
in extreme danger fighting was going on
either side of the embassy and that is
why the government took the decision uh
that it was essential to bring them out
we have a duty to all British citizens
of course but we have a particular duty
of care to our own staff and diplomats
she asked about the destruction of
material I can tell her that there was
time for all the normal procedures to be
adopted in that respect she asked about
our role at the United Nations Madam
Deputy speaker in in as the pen holder
there and as you will know we have
called uh already a meeting we will call
further meetings as appropriate and we
are discharging our duties as the pen
holder in every possible way she um
asked about the comparison with
Afghanistan and whether we had learned
lessons we most certainly have learned
lessons from Afghanistan and the
position in Sudan is completely
different first of all in Afghanistan
there were troops on the ground British
troops on the ground there are not
British troops on the ground in in
Khartoum and Sudan in Afghanistan the
airport was open and working the airport
in Khartoum is is out of action entirely
and thirdly there was in in Afghanistan
a permissive environment and so we had
the permission of the Taliban to take
people out there is no such permissive
environment at all in in Sudan and in
the capital city and finally she asks
about the humanitarian crisis she's
right the the humanitarian workers have
been shot at five of them have been
killed and prudently those involved in
the humanitarian Avatar withdrawing
their people this is a total an absolute
nightmare of a crisis where 16 million
people are already short of food and
support and it will only get worse as
she implied in her response unless there
is a ceasefire and the generals lay down
their arms and ensure that their troops
go back to barracks
chair of the select committee Alicia
cares thank you Melinda speaking can I
Echo those comments for the
parliamentarians showing my thanks to
those foreign office and mod staff who
evacuated our diplomats and their
families
the central tenet of the contract
between British Nationals and their
government were indeed the nation-state
is that of trust
and Trust at this point is being
stretched trust that we will evacuate
them and get them to a place of safety
when they are in need
whilst I recognize the complexity the
risk and that we have thousands of
Nationals when others have just hundreds
I do urge the minister and I recognize
that there is reportedly a
reconnaissance team now on the ground
and perhaps you can confirm there's a
major reconnaissance team there I do
urge my very right honorable friend to
get our people home because that is what
the foreign office and the mod train are
people to do
if however we are following the U.S
policy of non-evacuation or limited
evacuation we must have the moral
courage to tell our British Nationals
that that is the case because they are
running out of food they are running out
of water electricity and internet signal
some are killing their pets because they
know they can no longer feed them we
have a duty to empower them with the
information that they can have to make
the right decision for them and their
families but I would the minister the
time is running out we need to do the
evacuation now
minister
well I thank the chair of the select
committee very much for her comments and
I thank you also for her uh thanks to
the crisis center which is working uh
night and uh day
I I kind of show her that while the
United States have made clear that they
were taking out their diplomats in the
early operation which both they and we
conducted they have made clear that
they're not as things stand planning to
take out any of their citizens we have
not made that clear indeed we have made
clear that we are working at all levels
to try and ensure that we can we are
looking at every single conceivable
option and we will do as she suggests
everything we possibly can to help in
every way we can
Deputy speaker is very welcome to our
civil servants evacuated and all credit
all credit goes to the men and women in
uniform who delivered that operation the
political decision to evacuate an
embassy in these circumstances should be
neither complex nor lengthy so the
government may wish to cease
congratulating itself on that especially
as in terms of deploying our military
professionals to support ordinary
citizens trapped in Sudan the UK is
trailing as usual just as it did at the
start of the covert crisis when other
nations stepped up to repatriate their
people as is expected in such
circumstances the UK dithered and
Mildred can the minister explain to the
house the root cause of this
unfathomable inertia is this a tension
between the foreign office and the mod
and if so is the foreign office saying
goal and the mod is saying no or is it
the other way around ceasefire is the
answer to this crisis the official UK
government advice well what comfort that
do the thousands of UK Nationals still
on the ground you might as well tell
them Madam Deputy speaker to hold their
breath while we wait for food and water
to run out meanwhile this weekend France
evacuated 388 citizens including Dutch
Germany airlifted 101 to Jordan Italy
and Spain have evacuated their citizens
and those of Argentina Colombia Portugal
Paul and Mexico Venezuela and Sudan
turkey 640 people including people from
Azerbaijan Japan China Mexico and Yemen
and Ireland Madame Deputy speaker
without a tactical airlifter to its name
has evacuated its Irish Nationals and is
evacuating
140 more today what it is to have
friends in the world on Radio 4 this
morning the minister said that UK
Nationals in Sudan will be frustrated
won't Madame Deputy speaker they're
terrified they're not frustrated he also
said no fewer than three times that if a
Nationals and choose to independently
flee they will do so at their own risk
which rather exposes foreign office
priorities in this crisis in closing the
risk assessment taken by ministers
which advises UK Nationals to stay put
that this factor in any assessment of
access to food and water failing
sanitation or escalating violence making
future evacuations all the more hard
well
um Madam Deputy speak I don't agree with
the early part of his comments and it
was because uh diplomats were
specifically being targeted he will have
seen that the European union
representative was held up at gunpoint
and I have already mentioned that the
British Embassy was caught between the
two sides in this extremely dangerous
and I repeated what had happened for the
French it was a decision that our
diplomats were in extreme Jeopardy that
led to the operation which I have
described he will know as I said earlier
that we have a of course we have a a
duty of care to all our citizens and
that is why we are doing everything
possible within the art of the possible
to bring them home but we have a
specific duty of care to our staff and
our diplomats and because of the extreme
danger they were in that was why the
Prime Minister took the decision to
launch the operation which fortunately
was so successful
we chose the defense to elect committee
to buy or sell wood thank you madam
Deputy speaker could I also welcome the
statement and pay tribute to our
military in executing this uh evacuation
for our Embassy personnel
but as has been said that duty of care
must now extend to British passport
holders who are still caught up in Sudan
including my constituent Rita Abdul
Rahman who went to visit her father and
as our caught up in what's going on I'm
grateful for the communication over the
weekend with the minister but I hope he
recognized that whilst the capital is
very much dangerous the vast country the
rest of it is desolate and adds together
the elite forces of the United States
Britain France Germany Italy Sweden
that's a formidable Elite Force that
could mimic what the United Nations is
doing in using and protecting a land
Corridor to get the thousands of expats
and Internationals from the capital
indeed to Port Sudan and to safety when
he's considering it options would he
consider that as a possibility thank you
minister
oh thank you madam Deputy speaker well
my right honorable friend is a
distinguished former Soldier and he
understands the difficulties which we
face on on the ground I can tell him
that there's no reason to regard any of
Sudan as unsafe he will have seen what
is happening for example in Darfur uh
where the rsf is a successor body to the
ginger WID who wrought such havoc and
watched President George Bush described
as a genocide at the time but uh he will
he will understand therefore that in
terms of speaking about safety that is
not an easy concept to advance but what
I can tell him is that the option which
he mentioned and every option is being
very carefully considered and we will
resolve those options and move on them
just as soon as we possibly can
so Chris Bryant thank you madam W
speaker
um I too of course congratulate the art
that our Armed Forces who've done an
amazing job so far and commend the work
of um our diplomats
um but I too add my voice to those who
want to see as many of the people he's
already referred to a number of 2 000
British citizens
does he think it's more like four
thousand those are other numbers that
have been used elsewhere and what's the
best figure he can put in it and um can
I just urge him my memory of the
Afghanistan situation was the way MPS
had to relate to ministers was a
complete and utter shambles and some of
us in particular on this side of the
house felt that we had a very difficult
time trying to get any proper advice for
our constituents will he make sure that
in this second letter that is meant to
be coming to all of us that there is a
clearly identifiable number that we can
ring an email address that we can send
things to and we're not going off to
lots of different Departments of
government which end ends up just being
a complete and utter mess for everybody
Minister well I think I thank the right
honorable gentleman for his uh comments
he asked me really two uh questions
um the number of people who have uh
replied to the foreign office's request
for information and registered
themselves is of the order of uh 2000.
there are public speculation that
there's about four thousand uh British
Nationals that is of course British
Nationals and dual Nationals because if
you have a British passport you are
effectively in the same category so
those are the figures and I know that he
will accept me saying that lessons have
indeed been learned from what happened
in Afghanistan the second
um uh dear colleague letter which is I
hope in his inbox but if it's not it
will very shortly been as inbox does
indeed say exactly how to uh get hold of
the foreign office
um and uh we hope that the word shambles
will not be applied to the work that we
are doing seamlessly across government
to make sure that we achieve the aims
that are common across the whole house
armed for
CE Adam Deputy speaker and I can
absolutely understand how difficult and
dangerous any evacuation is and could be
the violent fighting was started by
General hermet is rsf it's really
worrying especially when you consider
the RSS historic links with Wagner I've
also met General hermeti and I will
never forget this overwhelming sense of
evil the longer the violence continues
the more people will face acute
shortages of food and water which could
then perpetrate even more violence so
can my right honorable friend tell us on
whether any food is actually getting in
to cartoon
sister
well I thank my right Uncle friend very
much for her comments and she knows
Sudan extremely well and the whole house
will have heard what she said about
General hermeti in terms of food she is
right to fasten on the fact that the
amount of humanitarian relief that is
getting in enormously needed but because
the humanitarian workers have been
attacked five of them have been murdered
it makes the whole issue of Supply
extremely difficult and as of now there
is very little food getting into uh
Khartoum we are acutely aware of this
and it is yet another reason why we are
pressing with our International Partners
our regional friends and partners
through the United Nations and its
agencies for a urgent ceasefire that
holds none of the ceasefires so far have
and urgencies for so that the
humanitarian as well as all the other
issues can be addressed O'Hara
Madam Deputy speaker my constituent
Jennifer McClellan has and her four
young children aged between 2 and 15 are
currently hiding in cartoon yesterday
Jennifer reported a significant Lull in
the fighting just at the time when other
foreign Nationals were being airlifted
out of the city by their governments and
she wants to know was that Lull in the
fighting coincidental or has the UK
missed a critical window in which to get
its Nationals out
and in the last couple of hours she's
been back in touch having heard rumors
that the Royal Navy could be heading to
Port Sudan and she wants to know if
those rumors are true but in the absence
of Consular staff how will she and her
family and others be evacuated from
cartoon to Port Sudan
Minister well Madam Deputy speaker I
cannot comment on rumors about the Royal
Navy and Port Sudan obviously his
constituent and her family should make
sure that they are registered with the
foreign office we will keep in touch and
everywhere everyone should be receiving
at least one communication per day but
uh I'm advised that today the internet
has only been two percent available so
there are real issues with that but we
will do everything we can he talks about
Allah in the fighting yesterday the
Turks had a convoy with three Master
points and when they were seeking to
congregate their people that two of
those muster points were shot up so it
is extremely dangerous and and it was it
would not be possible to say at any
point yesterday or indeed in any of the
days since uh this awful event took
place that Khartoum was in any way safe
thank you madam Deputy speaker Welsh is
always a very tricky decision to take as
to whether to evacuate staff and I
always felt the foreign office for a
little too Keen to evacuate staff rather
than protect British citizens is being
raised that the EU Embassy was shot at
and is directly opposite uh the UK
compound so I think it does so really uh
clear present danger to the the embassy
but my question is this and it follows
the question from The Honorable member
for Ronda will the minister estate be
more specific around numbers uh be more
specific on the 2000 number how many
dual Nationals how many mono Nationals
and whilst will Creek is your Nationals
uh equally will the Sudanese government
treat your nationality your Nationals uh
similarly and indeed how many of those
numbers actually want to stay because in
previous situations quite often your
Nationals are safer and want to say
hunker down with their families and
second communities
Minister well I thank my wife humble
friend for his comments um I can't
assure him having spent quite a lot of
time with the men and women who are
Manning the crisis center at the foreign
office that it would be quite wrong to
suggest that their concern was for
evacuating staff and not the wider
public the the absolute commitment to
the foreign office from the foreign
officers to do everything we possibly
can for all those who are caught in this
way although as I have mentioned before
we do have a special Duty in respect of
our own staff
um he asked me to be more specific about
numbers
um I think I have been quite specific
but the the published figure is about
400 for mono Nationals about uh four
thousand for uh dual citizens but he
will appreciate that if you have a
British passport then you would expect
to be treated in the same way whichever
group you belong to and as for how many
people want to leave Sudan as I said the
foreign office has received a registered
Communications from 2000.
Dan Jarvis thank you speaker can I
associate myself with the comments made
by the minister and the shadow Minister
about the professionalism and bravery of
those member of our Armed Forces who've
been involved with this operation I know
from my own time pghq that non-combatant
evacuation operations can be
particularly complex so well done to
everybody who's been involved the
situation on the ground as we've heard
from the minister is that there are 2
000 British Nationals who are registered
with the fcdo potentially out of um a
total of four thousand so given that
Sudanese telecommunications are
collapsing
can the minister set out and say a bit
more about what his department is doing
to explore contact with those British
Nationals who do not have access either
to a reliable phone signal or to the
internet
minister
well I first of all I Thank The
Honorable Warren Rowland gentleman for
his uh comments which come from very
considerable experience when I say that
the published figure for those who have
who are dual Nationals is four thousand
it may be more or less than that I'm
only giving him the published figure and
in respect of how we communicate with
people in in very difficult
circumstances we are indeed extremely uh
resourceful but he himself set out the
limitations for what is possible and we
work within those but I hope creatively
talk to Liam Fox Madam depth speaker may
also congratulate our Armed Forces on
their success thus far but at a more
strategic level given that the removal
of Bashir was key to stemming the threat
of islamist extremism in the region what
conversations has my right honorable
friend had with colleagues in
like-minded countries such as the UAE
and Saudi Arabia to ensure that whatever
the political outcome is in Sudan it
does not rekindle the threat of islamist
extremism which would have an impact on
Regional security and potentially our
own
minister
well from the former Defense secretary
is absolutely right in in what he says
and there is a real danger of the
cross-border spread of terrorism that he
describes he asked me specifically about
conversations with the UAE and the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia I can assure him
that those conversations go on at all
levels of government and indeed went on
over the weekend
Alison thulis much Madame Deputy speaker
when he came to the house last week I
asked him what what um the assurancy can
give to those Sudanese Nationals who are
already here in the UK and this morning
I got an email from my constituent
Muhammad who applied for Asylum 16
months ago because he was being
persecuted in Sudan he is still waiting
for some kind of incision from the home
office so can he speak to his colleagues
to offer some reassurance that those who
have sought Sanctuary here will not be
returned to a country in conflict
Minister I Thank The Honorable lady for
her comment um I do indeed recall what
she said last week I will refer the
matter to the home office that she has
raised but I kind of show her that no
one would be being sent home to Sudan at
the moment
all right Baldwin thank you madam Deputy
speaker and may I add my thanks to all
those involved in this crisis but last
week I thought that the minister rather
swerved my question when I asked how
much the overseas development assistance
budget had been reduced in Sudan so I
looked online and I saw that in fact uh
starting at the beginning of the 21 to
22 uh Financial year it really had
virtually disappeared and I wondered
whether the minister who was in the same
lobby as I was when we voted on 0.7
continues to believe that spending in
these fragile and conflict affected
Afflicted countries is actually a really
powerful way of preventing conflict
across the region
well Madam dep speaker I would never
purposefully try and swerve my right
honorable friends uh questions and uh
she uh and I were indeed in the same
Lobby and uh I would just point out to
her that uh Collective responsibility as
I mentioned to the house before is not
retrospective and in respect of the
funding in Sudan she will know that the
one area of the budget where there is a
degree of flexibility even in these
straightened times is in the
humanitarian area and clearly what is
happening in Sudan now will inform the
decisions we make in that respect
Kevin Robinson Madam Deputy speaker and
can I behalf of democratic unionists
Commander Armed Forces for their
significant efforts in what is the most
challenging and complex situation may I
invite the minister to recognize that it
may be a stretch to suggest that having
no diplomatic or military footprint in
Sudan at all has no effect on our
ability to rescue and evacuate British
citizens but having listened to Northern
Ireland resident last Wednesday who was
doing an interview ensconced in his
basement with his family in Sudan
highlighting that he was having to
siphon water from a top of his
neighbor's home and had little recourse
to food at that point on Wednesday how
do we assure him today that he hasn't
just been left alone
well Madam Deputy speaker I said in my
uh I thank you for his comments about
the Armed Forces um as I mentioned in
the statement Madame Deputy speaker uh
we do not think that the uh our
diplomatic reach is diminished in these
circumstances by diplomats being
withdrawn and that is because when they
were holed up in great Jeopardy uh in
Khartoum they were not able to operate
in most of the work was being done from
the crisis center in London and that is
the position today but I can tell him
that uh our teams in surrounding states
are moving to the point where they can
help anyone who comes in across the
border and the Diplomatic mission that
was uh resident Khartoum will be
relocating shortly to a neighboring
country
fence the Sudanese armed forces have
been reasonably helpful on evacuation
issues
but surely the best possible protection
for any future evacuation would be under
the auspices of the United Nations where
blueberries still count for a lot so can
my right honorable friend assure the
house
that the government is in the closest
contact with the UN to see whether or
not that extra degree of protection can
be obtained for any future extraction
operation
well I'm grateful to my right honorable
friend for his comments what I can
assure him is that not only is the role
of the UN under constant uh constant
examination to be progressed in any way
we possibly can but that as Britain
holds the pen and the jargon of these
things at the UN on Sudan we are leading
the efforts to make sure that all these
possible opportunities through the
United Nations are pursued
karenbach
you speak with a large Sudanese
community in Westminster no surprise
that I have a number of constituents who
are currently trapped terrified in
cartoon at least one of whom I have to
tell the minister has told me that he
has registered but has yet to hear
anything from the foreign office now I
also appreciate the difficulties with
the internet and I recognize also that
the minister may not want to be too
specific about what the future
communications might be as the hours and
days unfold but can he tell us whether
he's going to be able to advise MPS such
as myself and my constituents that there
that they will receive guidance as to
how any future evacuation plans will be
communicated to them so they are not
left in this interim period worried that
the minute the internet goes down that
they are totally abandoned
Minister well The Honorable lady is is
entirely right about the importance of
communication and I hope uh that my
second dear colleague letter will be of
assistance to her in her office in in
handling these extremely uh difficult uh
cases and in terms of the uh the the
communications difficulties which she
cited and which I mentioned in response
to another honorable member we are
looking at all possible ways of guidance
being delivered and I hope that we are
extremely creative in working out ways
of doing that but she may rest assured
that the full intellects and abilities
of the foreign office are engaged in
exactly that point
Deputy speaker there was already a
significant humanitarian issue in East
Africa which I know the government has
been working to help address this is
going to significantly increase the
humanitarian pressures on the region as
a whole as well as being potentially
disastrous for the people of Sudan can
the minister set out what resources we
already have in East Africa dealing with
humanitarian issues and what ability we
have to scale those up to meet the
inevitable challenge that will follow
this Dreadful conflict
minister
well I thank
um my right honorable friend he is right
about the scale of the issues which face
Us in East Africa the uh there are
something like 72 million people already
who are in need of substantial help
because of that and what is happening in
Sudan will make this infinitely uh worth
not least because they're already 60
million people who before this awful
crisis struck uh were profoundly food
insecure and in need of of assistance
um we we would scale up uh when the when
there's a cease fund when we're able to
do so in a way that he will understand
the United Nations agencies who are
extremely good at moving quickly to do
this when the opportunity arises will
certainly come into play organizations
like the world food program but many
others too but he will realize that the
indubitable requirement is that there
should be a ceasefire so they can
operate on the ground and as I have said
already five humanitarian workers have
been murdered during the last week
Richard Ford
Ford Madam Deputy speaker
I'd like to add my congratulations to
those involved in this Neo this
non-combatant evacuation operation and
I'd like to uh really carry on the
question a little further from The
Honorable member for West Worcestershire
British government has supported many
governments in developing countries over
the years with education on the Civil
oversight of defense and this includes
educating senior military personnel in
developing countries as part of our
program of Defense diplomacy
last year a liberal Democrat question
served to find that no training has been
provided by the mod two counterparts in
Sudan since 2020 because it would be
regarded as military aid does he think
education on the Civil oversight of
defense is worth categorizing separately
from military aid in those cases where
perhaps a a partner government might be
considering uh receiving it
well the audible gentleman makes makes
an interesting case of course through
the pooled funding Arrangements that we
have often that sort of work with the
military can take place but I can tell
him why he got the answer last year
um about Sudan it was because all our
efforts were bent to trying to support
the peace process and the negotiations
that were going on in order to achieve a
civilian a return to civilian uh rule
sadly uh all of that is now very much on
the back foot but that is the aim if we
can get a ceasefire that these political
negotiations should start so that there
can be a civilian government in Sudan
John Redwood a government advise UK
Nationals in difficulties to stay
indoors but what if they've run out of
food what if there is no power or or
other water or other utilities or what
if there is firing in the local area
what advice then and what message of
Hope for them
minister
well my right honorable friend makes
makes an extremely good point the only
advice which we can give through the
foreign office the only advice is to
stay indoors because of all the reasons
I've given during this statement about
the Jeopardy that is going on in the
streets outside we have changed the
advice today to say that while we think
people should undoubtedly remain indoors
if they can if they're not going to do
so they do it at their own risk but they
must make their decisions on the ground
and of course there are those who know
the situation around where they live
extremely well and may well be able to
exercise their judgment but they do so
at their own risk
to the hard-working staff at the crisis
center
last night a constituent's father who
had been shot at in Khartoum by armed
militia was evacuated by the generosity
of the French forces my office was
spoken to his family this morning they
are overwhelmed with grief they
mentioned that while Dad was had managed
to get out of the country down to sheer
luck one of our friends remains in his
apartment just three buildings down from
where Dad was the information trickling
down from the UK government remains
minimal and the announcement of European
countries evacuated citizens makes this
even tougher and given the reports that
there are over 4 000 British Nationals
currently in Sudan facing great danger
can a minister update us on how many
fcdo staff are currently responding to
this crisis and why it would appear to
be that the UK has been slower in
helping our citizens caught up in a
grave Danger
The Honorable lady will know that we
were the first along with the Americans
to intervene in terms of any extraction
whatsoever she asks me how many
civil servants are engaged and the
crisis center has 200 working there they
are working on shift but they are are
working throughout the night night and
day every day more or less since this
started a week ago
James Gray
that's because I asked the particular
questions maybe more General application
my younger situation age 24 has taken
refuge in the central official building
in Khartoum along I think with great
many others but her passport has been
locked up in her NGO buildings now
locked and sealed will therefore the
minister make sure that when any
evacuation does eventually occur some
kind of official travel documents May
well be available for those who don't
actually have them with them
my honorable friend makes makes an
important Point obviously it's essential
that his constituent does do their best
to contact the foreign office team so
that we are able to make a note of what
he says but uh I think I thank him very
much for uh informing us about that
specific problem
Martin Dr Hughes the proposition of
Madame Deputy speaker that Warren
conflict doesn't happen during High days
and holidays is a ridiculous one
therefore due to woeful inadequate
Intelligence on the ground it seems and
maybe the minister only gets the
dispatch box can correct me if I'm wrong
that the British prime minister the
British ambassador to Sudan decided to
go on holiday can you confirm that and
can you confirm if that's true who was
in charge Underground
but the the uh the Ambassador is
entitled to return to the UK either on
diplomatic business or indeed on leave
if that is appropriate but what I can
tell him is that the second most senior
uh person in the embassy in cartoon who
was the development director there uh he
was indeed in post when This Disaster
struck
given that there can be no guarantee of
de-escalation can my arrival friend
confirm that Cobra Cobra is meeting
regularly and urgently to consider all
evacuation options and will be prepared
to take risk in doing so and using the
strength of the UK Armed Forces if
needed
I can indeed confirm what my honorable
friend asks Cobra is meeting as we speak
Madam Deputy speaker it has met six
times uh so far five times chaired by
the Prime Minister including one Cobra
that we were at at 3 15 on Saturday
morning
Debbie Abrahams
but can I extend my thanks to the armed
forces and also everyone involved in
trying to resolve this crisis
I am still a little unclear from the
minister in terms of what he said is
what the plan is I appreciate he can't
provide operational details that might
put people at risk but can he at least
give a step-by-step outline of what the
plan is for example around international
relations in terms of ceasefire in terms
of evacuation that should be being
planned thank you
Minister I I thank her very much for her
comments about the Armed Forces she
asked me what is the plan and my answer
to her is very clear there are a very
wide range of options I hope fully
comprehensive which are being pursued
with Vigor on every possible opportunity
and Circumstance and as soon as we are
able to say more than that we will of
course tell the house
welcome thank you madam Deputy speaker
can I join other honorable and right
honorable members in congratulating our
Armed Forces for their very successful
operation over the weekend Madam Deputy
speaker a significant number of NHS
doctors come from Sudan and I understand
from a consultant at Stoke Mandeville
Hospital in my constituency that around
50 of these doctors from various
locations in the country are currently
trapped in or near Khartoum can I thank
my right honorable friend for the advice
his staff at the fcdo and indeed mine
will friend the Memphis Southwest
Hertfordshire provided at the weekend to
me and to my constituent who works there
at the earlier stage of this process but
does my right honorable friend agree
that it is incumbent upon those fighting
in Sudan to do all that is necessary to
enable those who wish to leave to do so
it is incumbent upon them to cease fire
and it's incumbent upon them then to
provide safe Passage
um I I thank um my honorable friend for
what he has said and in particular about
uh the uh doctors that he mentions
um and um in in respect of humanitarian
law the position is extremely clear and
it is clear that humanitarian law is
being breached on All Occasions in uh
Sudan so he is right to make that point
and can I also thank him for what he
said about the armed uh forces uh just
because the operation was an outstanding
success we should not forget the brave
men and women who put their lives on the
line who put themselves In Harm's Way in
order to protect uh the British cohort
in Khartoum
Oswald
the deputy speaker I have a constituents
who are trapped in cartoon they are NHS
doctors their colleagues are gravely
worried for them they're stuck with two
very small children and I've listened
carefully to what the minister has said
today and he said that there's a grave
risk to life that food and water scares
that the internet sparse that people may
wish to relocate at their own risk but
that's something that is very risky and
they have to exercise their own judgment
none of these statements are of any
practical help to my constituents who
really need concrete support to get them
and their children out of this
perilously dangerous situation so what
more can you tell us about the Practical
efforts being made to ensure that there
are food and water supplies on the
ground and what more can he tell us that
our constituents can take some comfort
from about the efforts being made to get
people back because nothing that I have
heard here today has given me any
comfort that my constituents should hope
to be back home where they belong at any
time soon
well I complete I completely understand
the frustration which The Honorable lady
and in particular her constituents will
feel at these uh events and I have to be
absolutely Frank with the house and
ensure that no one is misled the
position is extremely difficult and as I
have outlined both in my statement and
in my answer to questions we operate
within the art of the possible but she
may rest assured that we will do
everything we can and are doing
everything we can and have been doing so
since the start of this crisis to ensure
that her constituent gets home safely
and Manchester
thank you very much speaker just as it
was with the repatriation of British
Nationals during the covered pandemic it
seems that once again we are well behind
the curve compared to other countries in
the thousands of British Nationals still
stranded in Sudan will now be facing
food and water shortages along with
other dangers to their life but
according to Media reports it is
apparent that both the Ambassador and
the deputy Ambassador were out of Sudan
as early as the 14th of April can the
minister confirm if that is correct and
if so why was senior leadership not
present to help the British Nationals in
Sudan when they most needed them
Minister I don't think Madam speaker
there is a particular comparison with
the covid pandemic this is a very
different situation indeed it is very
different from the situation in
Afghanistan as I explained uh to the
house um a little earlier he he outlines
what he will understand as an
exceedingly complex and uh difficult
situation on the issue of Staffing uh
the uh the Ambassador was indeed out of
the country and the deputy head of
mission was not the second most senior
person in the embassy that was the
development of the development director
there as I explained in an answer to an
earlier question
Ronnie Cowan thank you very much Deputy
speaker
I've been contact by constitute of mine
who's Gravely concerned for family
members that are stuck in cartoon
including her great grandchildren
youngest of which is approaching three
years of age and I said in their
statement food and water are becoming
increasingly scarce so I get the
complaints to the situation but what are
we doing specifically to get food and
water to those people who are doing as
they were request you to do and staying
in their houses here here
Minister well once again I hope that the
dear colleague letter will be of
assistance in informing his uh
constituents uh on these matters in in
in terms of food and water the the
position is deteriorating even more
because the humanitarian workers are not
able to uh carry out their normal
activities but he will also understand
that we are operating within the art of
the possible and therefore what we have
to do is make sure that all options are
explored as rapidly as possible so that
we can bring help to those people who
are caught up in the Dreadful Jeopardy
that he so eloquently described
Samantha Dixon thank
you thanks um
kindly set out the arrangements in the
crisis center run by the fcdo
it's clear from listening to colleagues
across the benches that that
the fcdo and members of parliament are
going to be inundated with requests for
help so will the minister consider
stepping up and adding further support
to the crisis center because it clearly
seems to be needed
she is right to identify Madam Deputy
speaker the considerable amount of work
that is being done through and by the
crisis center as I mentioned earlier
working night and day there are 200
people engaged in that work and let me
assure her unequivocally that if any
more people are required we will provide
them
[Applause]